Trascrizione: Greta Longobardi
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Avevo sedici anni quando chiesi
alla mia docente di matematica e fisica
cosa volesse dire Einstein con la frase
le masse trasformano lo spazio-tempo.
Domanda strana, però io all'epoca
non avevo la fidanzata,
ecco perché le facevo.
La mia docente mi rispose
con un tono infastidito
"Adesso sto spiegando,
poi ne riparleremo".
Passarono due anni, ma dalla mia docente,
nessuna risposta.
Decisi quindi di laurearmi in fisica,
con una tesi proprio
sulla teoria di Einstein --
all'epoca, neanche avevo ancora
trovato la fidanzata.
E mi dissi: "Non so cosa farò nella vita
ma una cosa è certa, non farò
mai l'insegnante".
Proprio perché ripensavo all'episodio
che vi ho raccontato.
Bene, oggi sono un insegnante
mi occupo di ricerca didattica
e oggi vorrei parlarvi di un tema
per me molto importante,
che è l'educazione scolastica.
Ho scelto di fare l'insegnante
perché mi sono chiesto:
"Come posso far amare
la matematica e la fisica,
le mie discipline,
a chi incontro normalmente
tutti i giorni.
Come posso sradicare nelle persone,
che insegnare è noioso,
che fare matematica e fare fisica
è per pochi e devi esserci portato.
Ma soprattutto qual era e qual è
la mia idea di scuola.
Ho deciso quindi di partire da un oggetto
che avete normalmente anche voi in tasca
ce l'ho pure io,
che è lo smartphone.
Anzi aspettate un attimo ...
Vi ho fatto una foto.
Cosa ho fatto?
Ho utilizzato uno degli occhi
che ha il nostro smartphone.
Ma ha anche altri occhi. Uno di questi,
appunto, si chiama fotocamera.
Un altro è il sensore microfono.
Sapete, quando una particella
ad alta energia, tipo un raggio cosmico
oppure la radiazione emessa da un
elemento radioattivo,
passa attraverso la fotocamera,
questa rilascia un elettrone
che può essere misurato e
quindi studiato.
Potete, quindi, dopo che siete
usciti da questo teatro,
andare su una discarica, per esempio,
e vedere se ci sono
eventuali rifiuti radioattivi.
Oppure, questa notte per esempio,
rilevare l'eco di una supernova,
una stella esplosa centinaia di anni fa.
All'interno di uno smartphone,
vi è anche un altro sensore,
che usiamo normalmente anche questo,
che è il sensore magnetico.
Lo utilizziamo per trovare la bussola,
appunto, per trovare la strada.
Bene, a scuola noi lo utilizziamo
per misurare il magnetismo terrestre.
O ancora, per rilevare possibili
oggetti metallici sotto il terreno.
Utilizzando lo smartphone,
anche, diciamo, con un altro occhio
possiamo anche, per esempio, osservare
degli oggetti all'interno di un terreno,
ecco, trasformarlo in un microscopio.
Un giorno, mentre stavo spiegando
in classe un tema un po' particolare,
che è il moto circolare uniforme,
il mio alunno mi presenta questa foto.
Cosa aveva fatto?
Aveva semplicemente
studiato il moto circolare
tutte le leggi, le variabili, la velocità,
l'accelerazione, la forza centrifuga,
utilizzando il sensore accelerometro
all'interno del nostro smartphone.
Quello che di solito utilizziamo
per giocare, no?
E lo aveva fatto mettendolo all'interno
del suo oggetto preferito, la moto.
Vedete,
un oggetto del genere
in molte scuole oggi è vietato.
Cioè, i ragazzi lo devono riporre nella
tasca, lo devono mettere all'ingresso
all'inizio della lezione.
Ma molti di voi utilizzano lo smartphone
anche per altri scopi.
Se andate, per esempio, nella mia scuola
ma in qualsiasi altra scuola italiana,
i ragazzi durante la ricreazione,
tra un panino e una bibita
usano lo smartphone per giocare,
per fare i videogiochi.
Allora mi sono detto, perché non facciamo
matematica e fisica usando un videogioco
E quindi, con docenti da ogni parte
di Italia, abbiamo iniziato
a fare un gioco per farlo fare ai
bambini piccoli delle scuole primarie.
Abbiamo semplicemente detto loro:
"Potete costruire una casa.
Dovete lottare contro il tempo; avete
dei soldi a disposizione
e lo fate scegliendo dei materiali
in base alla loro sostenibilità ambientale
oppure in base all'isolamento termico".
E da allora abbiamo fatto
decine di videogiochi
per la didattica delle scienze.
Ad esempio, con i miei studenti,
abbiamo realizzato
abbiamo pensato di parlare del tempo,
dell'evoluzione Darwiniana
e lo abbiamo fatto realizzando un
videogioco su sette livelli.
In uno di questi livelli, tu sei
un pesce che vive in fondo al mare,
deve lottare contro altri pesci,
deve poter sopravvivere
contro queste specie, deve evolversi
per scalare l'evoluzione.
E se vi dicessi, ancora, che in un mondo
virtuale potete fare cose
che normalmente non potreste fare, tipo,
per esempio, simulare la caduta dagli sci,
oppure studiare lo scontro tra due auto.
I miei studenti, all'interno di un mondo
virtuale, possono immaginarsi
di essere Galilei oppure Newton.
Possono ricreare dei veri ambienti storici
mettendo trappole oppure insidie.
E non ho finito qui.
Mosso dalla curiosità dei miei studenti,
Mi sono avvicinato alla robotica.
Abbiamo quindi realizzato una serra
completamente automatizzata, dove
le piante vengono irrigate quando serve.
Il terreno viene concimato
e tutto l'impianto elettrico
viene gestito da un pannello
fotovoltaico mobile.
Con i videogiochi, con i bambini piccoli,
abbiamo fatto storia
ricostruendo, per esempio,
la battaglia di Maratona.
E, proprio in questi giorni,
stiamo lavorando insieme ai Centri Diurni
per Disabilità sul territorio,
per realizzare degli ausili
che possono loro rendere la vita migliore.
Di sera, ancora, i miei studenti,
con progetti territoriali
diventano formatori, fanno educazione,
e lo fanno insieme
ai giovani imprenditori.
Lo fanno insieme ai genitori,
lo fanno insieme ai NEET --
cioè coloro che non hanno più voglia
di cercare lavoro --
perché vedono nelle app,
nei videogiochi, nella robotica
uno strumento per migliorare il presente,
ed immaginare un nuovo futuro.
Vedete, nessuno di noi sa cosa faranno
i nostri adolescenti tra vent'anni.
Però una cosa è certa, essi dovranno
imparare a lavorare in team.
Dovranno imparare a progettare,
a condividere.
E l'utilizzo del digitale a scuola
ci restituisce proprio questo paradigma.
Ci dice: "Fidati di me,
collaboriamo insieme.
Indipendentemente se io sono più bravo
di te oppure meno bravo di te.
Soprattutto possiamo rendere reali
quelle che sono le nostre idee".
Noi docenti abbiamo quindi il dovere,
il dovere, di essere degli educatori.
E abbiamo ancora un altro importante
dovere, un compito,
quello di formare l'uomo,
l'uomo che vivrà
all'interno di una società
e in essa costruirà il suo futuro.
Credo in una educazione, in una scuola
in cui le parti come il territorio,
le famiglie, i genitori, le imprese
vivano sopra un tessuto
che è una sfera, quindi nessuno di essi
è posto al centro
ma possono collaborare tutti
sinergicamente,
costruendo appunto questo tessuto
che è l'educazione, l'apprendimento,
dove il digitale ne è
una trama consapevole ed attiva.
È la scuola questa, la mia,
dove non conta solo l'ABC,
dove matematica e fisica
non significa fare 1+1,
è la scuola quindi dello sviluppo
dell'autonomia, della creatività,
della fiducia nell'altro,
della collaborazione.
Cosa risponderei quindi oggi a un mio
studente che mi dovesse chiedere:
"Prof, ma Einstein
cosa voleva dirci con la frase:
'le masse curvano lo spazio-tempo'?
Oggi, questa domanda
me la fanno gli studenti --
a parte che ho trovato moglie,
quindi, insomma, non me le pongo più
queste domande ma ...
ne fanno anche altre di più strane.
Beh, io risponderei in questo modo --
come ho risposto poi realmente --
Rispondo: "Eccomi,
costruiamo insieme, sbagliamo insieme,
collaboriamo, io...
- bellissima la voce di sottofondo,
sono io -
ma soprattutto, abbi fiducia, io ne ho
più di te e, se alcune cose io non le so,
insegnale tu a me."
(Applausi)
Grazie.